hello everybody welcome to the david
pakman show i'm producer pat ford
filling in once again for david today as
he is traveling up north in canada but
fear not because david will be back with
us at the end of the week so let's jump
into some stories donald trump is taking
a huge political risk and demanding that
the full unredacted affidavit that led
to his search of his mar-a-lago home get
released to the public because he
believes that it's going to vindicate
him and the judge in the case bruce
reinhardt actually may decide to call
his bluff on this the affidavit of
course was the evidence that was used to
convince reinhardt that there was
probable cause to conduct the search
warrant at mar-a-lago trump's
spokesperson taylor budowicz said about
it quote president trump has made his
view clear that the american people
should be permitted to see the
unredacted affidavit related to the raid
and break-in of his home and trump
himself made the same call on truth
social aka trump essential posting there
is no way to justify the unannounced
raid of mar-a-lago the home of the 45th
president of the united states who got
more votes by the way than any sitting
president in the history of our country
not more votes than joe biden by the way
by a very large number of gun-toting fbi
agents and the department of justice but
in the entrance of transparency i call
for the immediate release of the
completely unredacted affidavit
pertaining to this horrible and shocking
break-in also the judge on the case
should recuse now what exactly should
judge bruce rinehart recuse himself for
nobody knows and will donald trump ever
articulate why he should recuse himself
probably not but it's just something you
throw out there i guess uh judge
reinhardt is actually open to the idea
of releasing the affidavit with some of
the appropriate redactions included the
specifics of which are going to be
recommended to him by next thursday but
the trump team it's not good enough for
them they want the full affidavit
without any redactions released to the
public which really should be no
surprise to us all because clearly trump
and his team are not too careful about
they how they handle sensitive
information which is exactly why he's in
this mess to begin with right that's
exactly why he decided to bring those
documents with him down to mar-a-lago
and put them in the basement redactions
would probably include cutting out some
of the names of the people involved in
the investigation of the former
president and they're totally fine at
the trump team just saying oh don't
don't cut out those names don't cut out
the very classified stuff that you don't
want released to the public because we
don't care if people get put in harm's
way over this now the call to release
the affidavit does seem to be a little
bit risky to trump because it could
reveal the communications between the
trump team and the doj ahead of the raid
which is when they asked him for
specific documents and if this comes out
this could totally debunk the claim that
trump has been making that he had this
great relationship with the doj and he
was cooperating fully thus the raid was
totally unnecessary it could also just
provide further evidence of how exactly
trump was mishandling classified
information which again is not a good
look for him it seems like the potential
upside to trump though is that if the
judge decides not to release the
affidavit
that's going to help him because trump
could say oh look they're not even being
willing to release all of the
information they're not telling us why
they're investigating me this is a witch
hunt they're trying to keep everything
secret by the way it's not common for
affidavits to get released to the public
they're just considering in this case
because of the public interest so maybe
the trump team thought that they make
this ask knowing that it wasn't going to
be granted to them but bruce reinhardt
seemingly willing to call his bluff and
this could end up backfiring
tremendously on trump and his team so
this is very much a part of the throw
everything at the wall and see what
stick strategy let's talk more about
that next ever since the fbi raid on
donald trump's home in florida a couple
of weeks ago we've been following the
right wings attempt to
throw everything at the wall and see
what sticks as it pertains to excuses
for the former president and they really
have tried everything right they've
tried saying that the fbi planted
evidence they tried saying that trump
was cooperating so you didn't have to do
this they tried saying that this is just
not how you treat a former president and
this is a political witch hunt all of
these different excuses right but now
we've got a new one and it comes to us
from
rudy giuliani who as we know is facing
enough problems right now because he is
the target of that election fraud
lawsuit in georgia rudy went on newsmax
and made the case that it was totally
fine that donald trump had those
documents with him down in mar-a-lago
locked away in the basement because they
were just as safe there as they would
have been at a government facility and
that's exactly why
he should be able to get away with this
without any consequences let's take a
look at the video of rudy making a fool
of himself
and and now
they want to make them responsible for
having taken classified documents
and preserve them
really if you look at the espionage act
it's not really about taking the
documents
it's about destroying them or hiding
them
or giving them to the enemy right it's
not about taking them and putting them
in a place
that's roughly as safe as they were in
the first place well to be fair to rudy
giuliani when hillary clinton's email
scandal was in focus he was actually
saying the exact same thing like he
would go on tv and he would talk about
how the emails stored on a private
server those are roughly as safe as they
would be if stored through the proper
channels of the government oh wait no he
actually he didn't say those things
funny how there's a double standard
between donald trump and hillary clinton
on this issue but what's funny about
this clip is that rudy actually debunks
himself in real time because he says
that if you look at the espionage act
it's not about taking documents it's
about hiding them destroying them or
giving them to the enemy well what
exactly is donald trump being
investigating for if not for hiding the
documents he brought them to mar-a-lago
and he hid them in the basement so
definitely debunking his own argument
there is rudy giuliani and then we also
know that trump liked to destroy
documents we've heard stories about him
ripping up documents we've seen the
pictures of him flushing the documents
supposedly 10 to 15 times and even
eating a document as omarosa alleges but
rudy manages in this clip to be wrong
about something else too which is pretty
impressive because it was only a 30
second clip that i showed you
which is that he was wrong about the
espionage act and what it says let's
take a look at the espionage act it says
whoever lawfully having possession of
access to control over or being
entrusted with any document writing code
book signal book sketch photograph
photographic negative blueprint plan map
model instrument appliance or note
relating to the national defense or
information relating to the national
defense which information the possessor
has reason to believe could be used to
the injury of the united states or to
the advantage of any foreign nation
willfully communicates delivers
transmits or causes to be communicated
delivered or transmitted or attempts to
communicate deliver transmit or cause to
be communicated delivered or transmitted
the same to any person not entitled to
receive it or willfully retains the same
and fails to deliver it on demand to the
officer or employee of the united states
entitled to receive it okay so that's
some impressively verbose legal jargon
there but if you cut through the fat you
see possession of access to or control
over defense information and then also
being unwilling to hand it over to the
proper authorities who are entitled to
it that's a violation of the espionage
act so rudy would have been better
served to read the law that he was
talking about before going on newsmax
and spewing nonsense about it on their
airwaves and then finally how are we to
believe that these documents were safer
than they would have been than at a
government facility or just as safe
because why they had a lock on them in
the basement at mar-a-lago is that the
argument you want to make so the
staffers at mar-a-lago the maintenance
people the custodians they could
probably get at least around that area
you best believe they don't have
security clearances so how is that in
any proper way the proper handling of
documents it's clearly not and then
we've also heard about how nonchalant
trump was when it pertained to sensitive
information at mar-a-lago while he was
president even making an impromptu
situation room on the patio at
mar-a-lago after north korea tested a
missile launch with guests of the resort
just walking by able to see exactly what
was being talked about between the
president and his team and remember
shinzo abe the late former japanese
prime minister was also there he must
have been absolutely shocked by the
entire thing so all the excuses from the
right for trump on this have been bad
they seem to be getting worse actually
we may at some point have to drop a
formal list of all of the horrible
excuses and rank them from best to worst
and my prediction is that this latest
one from rudy giuliani that the
documents were roughly as safe as they
would have been at a government facility
that has to be pretty high on the list
all right we're going to go to a break
now but we'll be back with much more of
the david pakman show right after this
one of our sponsors today is ketoned we
all have heard about the ketogenic diet
which puts your body in a metabolic
state of ketosis many have reported that
it's helpful for curbing hunger or even
weight loss ketoned is the top rated
ketone supplement on the market it
allows you to enjoy the benefits without
dramatically restricting your carbs and
if you already follow a ketogenic diet
ketoned is a great way to instantly
boost your ketone levels their formula
works in under 20 minutes take ketoned
advanced blend and then test your ketone
levels and see for yourself comes in
delicious flavors like aloha punch
tiger's blood citrus mango peach and
caramel macchiato or caramel macchiato
or caramel macchiato
ketone has helped millions of people on
their keto journey since 2016 read
online what ketone customers have to say
and ketoned is giving my audience 30 off
plus two free bottles of keto charged
when you go to
ketoned.com pacman and use the code
pacman at checkout
the misfortunes continue for mehmet oz
the tv doctor turned pennsylvania's
senate candidate we already knew that he
wasn't doing so well in the polls down
by as many as 11 points to democrat john
fetterman and he of course had his
crudite grocery store video go viral he
also got caught lying about how he
supposedly only has two homes when he
actually has 10 but now one of his most
important allies in the race donald
trump is seemingly giving up on him and
making matters worse is fox news which
is also piling on according to sources
at rolling stone trump has said about oz
quote he's going to effing lose trump is
also dumbfounded that someone who has
been popular on tv for so long is
performing so poorly but really trump
should just look at a mirror on that one
since he was losing in the polls for
much of the 2016 and 2020 election cycle
so it can happen right
trump asked his advisors whether the
polls may be skewed or phony and they've
had to tell them things like this is not
a matter of the polls being rigged there
are just major problems with the
campaign and specifically with dr oz as
a candidate trump also doesn't get
fetterman's appeal to voters he thinks
that he's in poor shape and he spends
too much time in the basement just like
joe biden did apparently trump just
doesn't get why people would prefer an
every man
caller type dude over an elitist
multi-millionaire in dr oz uh trump
however hasn't completely given up on
the race yet because he's going to be
heading over to pennsylvania on
september 3rd to do a rally for oz and
also for republican gubernatorial
candidate doug mastriano now if that
rally gets cancelled sometime between
now and then that's going to mean that
trump realizes there is no hope and
that's going to be the coup de gras in
the race master al masriano also is down
somewhere between 10 and 15 points so
trump may at some point decide to pull
the parachute and then you'll know that
this race is over as well as the
gubernatorial race and it's not just
trump turning away from oz even fox news
is doing it they ran a segment on dana
perino show last week covering dr oz's
latest gaffes the crudite video
fetterman trolling oz in a number of
different ways and it was just a very
unbalanced take you'd think that fox
news would give the advantage to the
republican as to how things went between
the two candidates but when you look at
this segment you realize no they're kind
of just piling on on dr oz's misfortunes
let's take a look at the clip in a viral
video you see dr oz he's walking around
a grocery store where he's talking about
how inflation is really hitting
americans hard and it's making things
more expensive in grocery stores
especially that crudite
started using grocery shopping i'm at
wig nurse and uh my wife wants some
vegetables protruded day guys that's
twenty dollars for kurute this doesn't
include the tequila
now fetterman attacked dr oz on twitter
as being out of touch noting most people
in pennsylvania call it a veggie tray
and the supermarket chain is called
wegmans not wagners and fetterman raised
over five hundred thousand dollars in
just 24 hours while giving out wegners
let them eat crudute bumper stickers dr
oz said look uh he was exhausted
campaigning when he made the video in
april and sometimes he even gets his
kids names wrong then fetterman attacked
dr oz for owning 10 properties with a
photo of a monopoly board with 10 homes
on one space tweeting pov you are dr oz
playing a board game he then noted that
monopoly was invented in new jersey a
swipe at dr oz for having lived in
jersey for three decades now dr oz
responded saying i purchased my homes
with my money you lived off your parents
until you were almost 50 get off the
couch john now look this is a battle
over likability the latest fox news poll
shows fetterman is viewed favorably by
49 percent of voters dr oz is viewed
unfavorably by 55 percent of voters and
so they really got to everything in that
little segment didn't they they got to
the grocery store gaff john federer's
response to it with the veggie tray and
then they got into the monopoly board
and the 10 houses on boardwalk and how
monopoly was invented in new jersey
and sure they showed dr oz with that
tweet trying to fire back but it fell
flat obviously fetterman has gotten the
best out of these exchanges and he knows
the troll game a lot better than mehmet
oz does so that's the latest on this
race it's been one of the most
entertaining races to follow and we
can't just call dr oz completely out of
this at this point everyone has to vote
but we'll see if the trend continues in
this direction if federer is able to
really squash him by going up 15 maybe
20 points in the polls then we can start
celebrating a little bit early i'd say
but everyone has to vote and it's not a
surefire thing just yet but things are
definitely looking good for john
fetterman lindsey graham has been in a
bit of trouble recently but he actually
got a minor victory yesterday when an
appeals court ruled that the south
carolina senator can have a chance to
challenge the order that he got to
testify in the georgia election fraud
case because of protections for
lawmakers under the constitution's
speech or debate clause graham has been
ordered to based on a subpoena that he
got appear tomorrow to talk about the
calls he made to georgia election
officials in the wake of the 2020
election and this is all part of an
investigation seemingly not so much into
graham but into the person who is in
charge of the entire scheme and that is
of course donald trump and first graham
and his lawyers were saying that what he
did with his phone calls to people like
secretary of state brad raffensberger
they were simply part of his job duties
as a us senator because as a lawmaker
it's important that he is able to make
sure that the election systems in all
the different states are on the up and
up but then that argument was quickly
turned down because of course graham
represents south carolina not georgia so
why is the election process in georgia
any of his business it's not and that's
why that argument was turned down but
fast forward and graham filed an
emergency request with the u.s court of
appeals for the 11th circuit asking it
to put the subpoena on hold while his
appeal played out and now the appeals
court has ruled it wants both sides to
argue what areas of questioning would be
appropriate for a us senator a sitting
u.s senator especially and so there's
going to be a stay this was supposed to
happen tomorrow and it's not going to
happen as was initially planned graham's
attorneys say that he will suffer
irreparable harm if forced to appear
before his appeal concludes which may be
true but i think it's going to be
irreparable harm in the form of trump
and trump voters including the voters of
south carolina which is quite a red
state and they may not be so happy if
graham decides to spill the beans on
trump in this testimony and the district
attorney's office as you might imagine
is getting sick of graham's delay
tactics they've been going on for weeks
and weeks now the office is saying that
graham is crucial to the investigation
and that he is expected to provide
information regarding additional sources
of relevant information it is true that
uh if he has to eventually testify
then he may just decide to be obstinate
like he may just plead the fifth a bunch
of times as we recently saw donald trump
do in a different investigation but if
he decides to ignore this thing
altogether after being forced into
delivering a testimony maybe he'll open
himself up to criminal charges so i
think he will at least cooperate in some
way if it's determined that he has to
because graham loves to just grovel to
whoever has influence and authority over
him at any given moment like for a while
that person seemed to be john mccain the
two were inseparable right uh and then
of course mccain passed away so that put
an end to that relationship and then
graham when he ran for president in 2016
trump doxed him so you'd think that that
would put cram on opposing sides to
trump like he wouldn't be a trump fan
after that but then eventually graham
came around to liking trump and being in
one of his lackeys because trump became
the figurehead of the republican party
so what else could he do he had to
gravel at his feet and then after
january 6th it looked like the party and
especially the politicians in power were
moving away from donald trump so what
did lindsey graham do he made this big
speech on the night of january 6 talking
about how this was unacceptable and him
and trump had this long road but that
was over with and joe biden and kamala
harris legitimately won the 2020
election and then it only took a few
weeks maybe a couple of months before he
decided to go back to uh groveling hits
donald trump's feet because he knew that
the party and the constituents were not
ready to move away from trump and so
that's lindsey graham for you if he just
realizes that hey these prosecutors in
georgia they have the goods on me and
they have authority over me right now
he's going to decide to change his ways
ultimately though if they're not able to
get graham to testify i don't think that
this is going to change the course of
the investigation if they want to charge
donald trump in this they seem to have a
rock solid case i mean they have that
phone call with raffensburger where
trump asked for the 11 280 votes and all
these other calls and repeated attempts
like if they want to get trump on this
it seems like they can but you might as
well try to make it an even more rock
solid case and that's why they're trying
to get graham on board with this too but
at least for now graham's able to fend
off the order to testify republican
leaders across the country have been
knocking joe biden for the high
inflation rate in the looming recession
saying that if only we had a steady hand
in the white house if only we had
republican leadership we wouldn't be in
all these different problems but
unfortunately for them these red states
are dealing with inflation too and in
many of these areas within these red
states the inflation rates are above the
national average like for example in
texas we have governor greg abbott who's
been attacking joe biden for inflation
but if you look at the inflation rate in
the houston area it's 10.2 percent and
it's 9.4 percent in the dallas area
which is quite a bit higher than the
national average of 8.5 percent florida
governor ron desantis and georgia
governor brian kemp have also been
knocking biden for the inflation rate
even though in the miami area
inflation's at 10.6 percent in tampa
11.2 percent and atlanta 11.5 percent
but at the same time many of these same
republicans who are attacking biden for
inflation they're taking credit for
these strong jobs numbers that are
happening in their states the associated
press found a familiar pattern in 15
republican-led states in which governors
on twitter would praise job growth in
their states so like for example we have
governor greg abbott from texas he was
saying last month quote the u.s economy
is in a recession under biden meanwhile
texas was number one in the nation for
job growth in june and more texans have
jobs today than ever before in our
state's history now even though it's
dishonest it actually does make sense
for these republican governors to make
the case from a political standpoint
that the economy is so great in their
states but in the toilet nationally and
that's because voters tend to not be
able to see through it they hold the
state economy and the national economy
to different standards let's say you're
in florida and things are not going so
well for you you're going to be more
likely to blame joe biden for the
inflation rate gas prices what have you
than you would be governor ron desantis
you don't think that the census has much
to do with it but if you extend this
logic a little bit further you see how
absurd it is right because you could
look beyond the state you could look
beyond the country and just look at
things from the world level
and you would understand that the entire
world right now is dealing with
inflation in some form it's just one of
those things where we're trying to get
back on track post the pandemic and if
you look at the european union they have
to raise interest rates now because
their inflation rate is at a sky high
8.9 percent canada also has high
inflation there at 7.6 percent like this
is not a issue that is unique to the
united states but because so many
americans and republicans especially
seem to be unaware that there is a world
outside of the us it's not just all
about us and all of our economies are
interconnected because they don't
realize that they just think that the
buck stops with biden entirely on this
which which it doesn't and you know it's
not like you can just pass some policy
or decide to spend less money or
whatever and poof the inflation problem
would be gone it's a lot more
complicated that than that and you know
the truth is governors nor presidents
have much to do with a lot of these
economic indicators like inflation like
gas prices and we'd be much better
served if the general public knew that
but for now with the public being
ignorant on it republicans are able to
take advantage of the public's ignorance
and keep winning elections unfortunately
we're going to go to a quick break we'll
be back with much more of the david
pakman show right after this
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
is not happy with the quality of
candidates that republicans have been
offering up for the 2022 midterms and
this story really feeds into the growing
rift within the republican party as they
try to figure out what direction they
want to go in with donald trump's
political future being so uncertain at
the moment mcconnell was speaking to
reporters and he sort of alluded to the
fact that republicans really should be
shoeins to win both the house and the
senate if you look at historical
president with we know the president
who's in power tending to have a bad
first midterms and also the economic
indicators that aren't really going
democrats way but mcconnell points out
that some of these races tend to be up
to the personalities of the people
running in them and he mentions without
saying specifically that a lot of these
candidates are weak and wacky so here's
what mitch mcconnell had to say
i think
there's a probably a greater likelihood
of the house flips
than the senate
senate races are just different they're
statewide
candidate quality has a lot to do with
the outcome so mcconnell actually is
quite right on this which is not
something that i often say about him but
i do think that he's right on both
fronts here like for one republicans are
definitely more favored to win the house
than they are the senate if you look at
the 538 odds republicans currently have
a 78 chance at winning the lower chamber
but only a 37 percent chance at flipping
the upper chamber and then yeah people
generally want rational competent
intelligent sound-minded people
representing them regardless of
political affiliation that's sort of
like the base level of things that
people want in a candidate and in a
house race maybe you can get away with
having a whack your candidate because
there's not going to be all that much
attention paid to them but in a senate
race it's going to get statewide
attention maybe even national media
coverage so you can't always get away
with having a whack your candidate and
if you look around the country
republicans are not sending us their
best to paraphrase donald trump in
georgia you have former football player
herschel walker who often fails to make
any sense at all
and he hasn't really expressed that he
knows anything about policy matters in
pennsylvania you have mehmet oz who is
coming off as an elitist with a hundred
million dollars and a carpetbagger from
new jersey who just thinks that he's
entitled to a senate seat because he's
been on television for so long in ohio
you have jd vance who went from being a
somewhat reasonable republican who wrote
the hillbilly elegy to now being a
full-on trumpist who said that it's
sometimes better for people in abusive
relationships to stay together rather
than get divorced and then in wisconsin
you have incumbent ron johnson who often
spreads disinformation about the 2020
election voter fraud and
coveted vaccines and wisconsin's not a
red state it's a it's a blue state maybe
a purple state you could call it so
they're definitely far to the left of
where ron johnson is so it's not
surprising that he's also losing in the
polls but at this point there's no going
back right you're stuck with most of
these candidates most of the primaries
have already happened at this point
there's about 10 toss-up races in the
senate this year and i do think that
democrats are poised to win much of them
and hold on to their majority maybe even
pick up a seat or two or three which
would be awesome because then we can
talk about getting rid of the filibuster
and pass more of our progressive wish
list assuming we're able to also hold on
to the house but that's a conversation
for another day
but someone who did not like mitch
mcconnell's statements were
fox news propagandist sean hannity he
said this about the statements now the
same democrats are painting republican
senate candidates running an upcoming
elections and midterms as cruel and out
of touch well apparently senator uh
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
is content to leave them out to dry and
fend for themselves
how about you get out there mitch and
fight for your team
what's your agenda mitch or would you
rather just sit by and watch helplessly
as democrats lie to your face pass
another 500 billion dollar green energy
boondoggle next year or is it maybe
mitch mcconnell hates donald trump so
much that he would probably rather see
trump endorse candidates lose because he
thinks that might hurt donald trump his
time as a leader needs to come to an end
and it is true that the nrsc the
national republican senatorial committee
has already decided to pull back a lot
of their tv ad spending dollars because
they're just giving up on certain races
they don't think that there's any point
spending any money because it's just
going to be a waste they might as well
consolidate that money and spend it in
the places where they do have an actual
shot at winning and they've already
spent a lot of their money over the
summer now they're having a tougher time
fundraising because the political wins
seem to be going back in the democratic
direction and so republicans are in
chaos right now they thought that they
would have this big red wave this
midterms and now it's not looking so
great we're seeing people turn on one
another we're seeing the rats leaving
the ship and as someone who is not on
their side i like to see it happening so
i just spoke about how mitch mcconnell
told reporters he doesn't like
republicans chances at winning the
senate in 2022 because senate races have
a lot to do with candidate quality
sort of alluding to the fact that he
doesn't think a lot of these republican
candidates are high quality candidates
and are a little bit too out there to
win these elections let's take a look
again at the clip as a reminder i think
there's a probably a greater likelihood
of the house flips
than the senate races are just different
they're statewide
candidate quality has a lot to do with
the outcome well another person in
addition to sean hannity who is furious
with mcconnell's comments here is donald
trump who of course has invested
interest in the outcome of the 2022
midterms because he needs to see this
big red wave with as many of his
candidates winning as possible in order
to feed into the narrative that you need
trump as figurehead of the republican
party if you want to win back the white
house in 2024 so trump made a statement
on truth social bashing mcconnell which
isn't all that new really trump has been
treating mcconnell as a pinata for years
now but he even went so far as to bring
mcconnell's wife into the mix and call
her crazy trump said quote why do
republican senators allow a broken down
hack politician mitch mcconnell to
openly disparage hard-working republican
candidates for the united states senate
this is such an affront to honor and to
leadership he should spend more time and
money helping them get elected and less
time helping his crazy wife and family
get rich on china so i believe that what
donald trump is doing here is setting
the groundwork in place to have
something else to blame the 2022 midterm
defeats on in the event that his
candidates lose their respective races
and he really just has so many built-in
excuses at this point like if an
anti-trumper or a half-trump supporting
candidate loses their race well he can
just jump in and say that's because they
were against me they were not a true
pro-trump candidate and that's exactly
why they lost if you have a pro-trump
but doesn't want to talk about him too
much type of candidate someone like a dr
oz for example and they lose will trump
could jump in and say well that's
because they weren't embracing me enough
right i tried to do a rally in their
home state and they turned me down if
they had embraced me more clearly they
would have won and then in this sort of
situation if you have someone who is a
full-on pro-trump supporting candidate
where those excuses that i laid out
previously wouldn't work now he can just
blame mitch mcconnell he can say that
well mitch didn't believe in the
candidate and the nrsc the national
republican senatorial committee they
didn't spend enough on their race and
that's exactly why they lost it has
nothing to do with me and then the all
of the above excuse he can always use is
that there was voter fraud so you always
have that one in your back pocket too
that's a favorite among republicans
these days and then the second
interesting thing about this post by
trump is the choice to go after mitch
mcconnell's wife who is elaine chao chow
worked in trump's cabinet she was his
transportation secretary and she
actually resigned in protest after the
january sixth capital riots so
apparently that's what got her on
trump's bad side and that's why trump
sees her as crazy now and you got to
wonder how mitch mcconnell is going to
respond to this if he's going to say
anything about it at all because we know
that mcconnell has been very wishy-washy
about trump in recent years he clearly
doesn't like trump he doesn't like the
power that trump has over him and the
rest of the republican party but at the
same time he knows that his kentucky
constituents like trump and he knows
that if he wants to remain in charge of
the republicans in the senate he still
has to at least give lip service to
trump being in charge of everything and
um because otherwise they'll decide to
oust him as the minority leader and so
he's in this horrible position of having
to maybe defend the person who just
insulted his wife it's exactly what ted
cruz had to face a couple of years ago
where trump called cruz's wife ugly and
despite how humiliating it was cruz
eventually had to come around and defend
trump back him support him phone bank
for him and just become a normal
trumpist so we'll see if mitch mcconnell
decides to go the ted cruz route or if
he'll have a little bit more courage and
decide to stand up for his wife what an
incredible situation that mitch
mcconnell finds himself in and clearly
trump hasn't learned his lesson that you
shouldn't go after people's spouses
because why would he ted cruz let him
get away with it so maybe mitch
mcconnell will too and uh will this lead
to mcconnell being more aggressive
against trump i'm not gonna hold my
breath republicans are continuing their
crusade against mail-in voting we know
that the party as an electoral strategy
wants the fewest number of people voting
as possible as that is what provides
them with the best shot at winning
elections we know that the right has
these retrograde ideas as it pertains to
policy matters and so their strategy for
winning elections over the past many
decades now is to simply play these
dirty tricks like gerrymandering which
we talked about on friday's show being
efforts to expand voting access by
making election day a national holiday
for example
or instituting same-day voter
registration and the new vocal point
from the republicans over these past
couple of years has been to talk about
vote by mail and how it's so horrible of
course vote by mail's popularity has
increased with the pandemic and more
people voting is just not good for them
so they have to put a stop to it by any
means necessary but they can't just say
that higher voter turnout is something
that they're opposed to because that's
what makes them sound like they're
anti-american or undemocratic small d
undemocratic and so they have to come up
with another reason for being against
vote by mail and that is voter fraud
which they claim and make all these
allegations but are never able to prove
and with the midterm elections now upon
us it's time for the right-wing media
sphere to really ramp up the rhetoric
insert tucker carlson and his guest
chuck devore who decided to complain
about the postal service creating a
division to handle election mail and
tucker makes the case that if you can't
be bothered to vote in person well then
you shouldn't have the right to vote at
all let's take a look at the clip well
the postal service is now actually
taking an active and explicit role in
our elections but not on behalf of trump
they've created a dedicated division to
quote handle election mail ahead of the
2020 midterms why are they doing this
exactly and what are the implications of
it chuck divorce with the texas public
policy foundation he's written a
fascinating story on this he joins us
now chuck thanks for coming on what is
this exactly
well tucker this is a very concerning
development because the
government unions that represent the
postal workers always endorse democrats
the further to the left the better and
we have evidence that they mess with
elections they mess with election mail
now of course that mail-in ballots are
taking on a greater and greater uh
significance in our elections we see
this new division the special division
created in the postal service to deal
with election mail and tucker i i just
don't think that people should be
trusting the postal service with their
mail-in ballots they ought to be voting
in person with government-issued id to
be totally safe
why is there any mail in balloting if
you can't be bothered to get to the
polls why are why do you have a right to
participate in democracy i don't unders
i don't understand i mean it's just an
invitation to fraud they support it
because it allows fraud why are
republicans putting up with this
well they're putting up with it because
voters like the convenience and they
certainly like the convenience until
former president trump warned them about
the dangers of it so now you're
beginning to see this division between
republicans who are becoming more
skeptical of mail-in ballots and
democrats who love them because of
course you can send people to the house
of voters and help them fill out the
ballot and make sure that they vote for
the right people so what happens with
mail and ballots tucker is you lose the
secrecy of the ballot
and that's a very important thing that
people i think just forget about
and no one trusts elections and so then
the system really does degrade it's
built on trust this undermines trust
it's poison obviously chuck divorce i
appreciate your reporting on this thank
you so first of all i like the sounds of
this special election mail division at
the post office because we know about
the efforts in the last election by
trumpist postmaster general louis de joy
to slow down mail delivery times so that
voters would miss their deadlines that
to me sounds like politics being played
at the post office that we need to put a
stop to but then just imagine if they
decided not to make such a division at
the post office then republicans could
just make the opposite point they could
say well given how sacred our election
process is shouldn't there be an added
layer of scrutiny shouldn't be the
process be a little bit different than
how your grandma sends you a letter for
your birthday why isn't there more
protection so you best believe if the
shoe was on the other foot they would
just be making the opposite argument and
then tucker's guest goes on to talk
about how the usps supposedly backs
democrats more than they do republicans
assuming that's even true by the way
maybe it has to do with the fact that
republicans for generations have tried
to turn the post office into a
quasi-private institution and they tried
to make them bankrupt for so long by
making them pay their employees benefits
years out in advance when no other
institution in the country has to do
that but this is exactly what
republicans do right like they love to
gut certain departments and then when
those departments don't
function properly or as efficiently they
say look we need to get them even more
and instead look at private solutions um
and then when they decide to complain a
little bit over at some of these
agencies well all of a sudden they're
democratic actors right they're being
political and that's an excuse to defund
them even more so that's the game that
republicans love to play on this and
then we get to tucker carlson's hot take
which is that if you can't get to the
polls then you don't deserve to vote
well let's think about all the different
people that that would exclude because
it's not just democrats you'd be
excluding if you decided to go along
with such an idea there'd be plenty of
people in these demographics that would
be republican voters you'd also be
leaving out so people who tend to vote
by mail include people who are in the
military
americans living overseas nursing home
residents
people who are immuno-suppressed and
avoid going out in public too often
because they fear catching kovid
students away at college and oh yeah
donald trump who voted by mail in march
of 2020 in the primaries apparently he
was in dc for work he was working a
certain job at the moment and just
couldn't be bothered as tucker would put
it to travel to florida in order to cast
his ballot so
they love to talk about voter fraud
because it's a way for them to push
voter suppression they know that if they
just talk about how they want fewer
people voting that that would be a bad
look so instead they have to come up
with this voter fraud excuse even though
they haven't been able to prove the
allegations over time they just keep
making the claims and it doesn't matter
to the supporters they just believe it
hook line and singer and uh it's just
it's just nonsense we have to move away
from this but republicans as long as
they're continuing to lose elections
will keep making this point as an excuse
for why they lose
brian stelter is out of a job at cnn
with the network deciding to cancel his
weekend program reliable sources a show
that's been on the air for 30 years the
last nine of which brian stelter hosted
and this is part of cnn's attempt to
rebrand itself we know that cnn used to
try to play the role of being a down the
line corporate media outlet positioning
itself as the rational center between
fox news on the right and msnbc on the
left going with the most trusted name in
news moniker then the trump years rolled
around and they shifted into being a
more outwardly anti-trump network more
opinionated becoming a lot more just
like an msnbc alternative but now with
some changes over at cnn with jeff
zucker out with chris cuomo out with cnn
plus failing miserably they have the
room to make some image changes and it
looks like they're going back in the
direction of being a more hard news down
the line network uh and i'm sure they'll
still be worthy of plenty of criticism
right because they probably will
continue to try to be neutral instead of
objective they'll be too corporate too
sensationalist focus on two stories but
to me at least i do think that this
makes sense for them to go in this
direction because there seems to be more
market share trying to be the centrist
news outlet with so many other cable
news outlets being left or right and it
seems like the change is largely being
influenced by john malone who is the
most powerful investor over at warner
brothers discovery inc that's the parent
company of cnn and malone is a right
slash libertarian guy he's not a
trumpist but he's definitely
conservative he actually likes to watch
fox news reportedly and i don't know if
you've seen this but over at fox they
absolutely love to bash brian stelter
whenever given the opportunity so it
makes sense that
after seeing all that fox news that
malone would want to go in the direction
of ousting brian stelter in favor of
someone else and you know just with the
network trying to make all these changes
generally there was just no room for
stelter unfortunately for him and then
there's also the money angle too right
because stelter was reportedly making
almost a million dollars a year despite
the fact that his show is only getting
five hundred thousand to six hundred
thousand viewers per episode so looking
at the business side of things it just
doesn't seem to add up and final point i
wanted to make on this i do like the
idea of having a media literacy show out
there something with the idea of being
focused on the media a watchdog for the
media but is cnn the right place to have
a show like this because you can't
pretend to be the arbiter of good
journalistic practices
when it comes to other networks when you
yourself at your network are also going
to be victims of the same sort of biases
and problems right you're just not in a
position where you have the credibility
to do a show like that and it often
would create this conflict of interest
where you don't cover your same your own
network with the same sort of scrutiny
that you'll cover other networks like i
remember when cnn plus failed stelter
went on the airwaves and he talked about
how it was really too early to tell
whether or not uh cnn plus was a success
because it only made it a couple of
weeks or a couple of days whatever it
was and so it was just too early to tell
well if msnbc or fox news's streaming
network failed so early would he have
had the same commentary i don't think so
something tells me his uh takes would
have been a little bit different and of
course you can just decide not to cover
what's going on at your network at all
so it created all these conflicts i just
don't think that cnn was the right place
for it and that is the latest reliable
sources canceled after 30 years the last
nine of which brian stelter hosted and
now he's out of a job looking for
somewhere else to work sona marin the
prime minister of finland has been under
fire lately for one of the dumbest
political scandals imaginable for
partying and dancing and having a good
time the clips of which were made public
marin is 36 years old making her one of
the youngest world leaders and good for
her she likes to have fun every now and
then go to house parties and nightclubs
and dance presumably have a few drinks
and just all around have a good time and
she's actually had to respond to
criticism over this both from the
finnish people and from people across
the world there are some right-wing
commentators here in the us who are
making a fuss about this saying that
this is unbecoming of a prime minister
what if she was on drugs what if there
was an emergency that she had to deal
with at that very moment what would the
world have done and it's clear to me
that a lot of these attacks are ageist
and misogynistic because he wouldn't
make them about an older man for example
but let's first check out the ever so
controversial video of her partying and
having a good time
[Music]
[Music]
all right so if you were just listening
and you weren't watching along there
she's just dancing and making some cool
poses and having some fun with her
friends there's really nothing out of
the ordinary about it but despite all
this she had to give a response to
reporters marin has said in response to
the videos that she's agreed to take a
drug test which i don't think that she
should have had to do or should have
been pressured into but the results of
that drug test are supposedly going to
come out within the week and she's also
made the statement i did nothing illegal
which is very much true and even in my
teenage years i have not used any kind
of drug and then in response to the idea
of like oh well what if an emergency
came up uh she said i don't remember a
single time that there was a sudden
situation in the middle of the night to
go to the state council palace i think
my ability to function was really good
there were no known meetings on the days
i was partying so this readiness to
respond if there was an attack or
something seems to be based on the
presumption that she was drinking and we
don't know by the way if she was
drinking or drinking to excess but even
if she was like this is not a standard
that we hold to other leaders other
world leaders that they can't have a
drink every now and then that they can't
get a little buzz going why is this
being unfairly applied to her and then
after the initial clips came out we also
got a clip of marin dancing with someone
who is not her husband and some people
were upset with that even though if you
look at the video the dancing seems
pretty platonic and she's actually
trying to back away from the guy who's
making advances on her she at one point
puts her arm up so that's the situation
anyway for her to deal with her husband
with right it's not really a matter of
public interest in my opinion but just
it's another thing that they can
criticize her for and the big takeaway
really is that people need to chill out
a little bit and let loose and not take
things so seriously all the time and if
you're one of those people who are just
too uptight and you can't let loose
every now and then at least let other
people let loose and not take things so
seriously all the time and also let's
apply these criticisms equally please
like when donald trump danced to the
ymca
people were making criticisms about his
dancing abilities right because it
looked kind of awkward but aside from
that no one was saying oh he needs to
take a drug test and this is unbecoming
of a president of the united states and
what if we were attacked at that given
moment would he have been able to
respond no one was saying that but
apparently people are willing to make
these criticisms against marin because
she actually can dance and she's young
and a woman and all these different
things so it's definitely a double
standard it's pretty transparent and the
bottom line is people just need to chill
out and apply these standards equally so
we have a bit of a light-hearted story
to wrap things up today and it has to do
with one of the worst pandemic inspired
changes to our society which is of
course the dreaded qr code at
restaurants replacing physical menus we
know that during the pandemic businesses
would try to take advantage of the
situation by not providing us with
things that we were used to and just
using kobat as an excuse like they would
say oh sorry we can't clean your hotel
room because of covid and sorry you
can't bring your reusable bag to the
grocery store because of coba remember
that one well none of these changes were
as bad as the dreaded qr code scanner at
restaurants and while some of the
pandemic era inconveniences are no more
the dreaded qr code at restaurants
persist and the idea of introducing them
in the first place was pretty clear you
don't have people touching the menus
that way you don't have to sanitize the
menus as often and it's the same reason
why restaurants during the height of the
pandemic got rid of the ketchup bottles
on the tables and the salt and pepper
shakers and it didn't take long for us
to learn that the virus was largely an
airborne transmitted virus it didn't
really transfer that much from surfaces
so a lot of these changes that we made
were pointless and we could have
backtracked on them right then and there
pretty early on in the pandemic but
restaurants persisted with the qr thing
because printing menus can be expensive
you need to replace them sometimes when
they get dirty or when you change the
menu you got to think about the printing
costs and it's also in a low labor
environment just better for businesses
to have the qr codes because you don't
have to have staff distribute and
collect the menus but customers
absolutely revile the qr code myself
included a recent technomics survey
found that about 88 percent of
respondents said that they preferred
paper menus to digital qr codes about 66
percent of respondents agreed or
strongly agreed that they didn't like qr
codes because they involved pulling out
your phone as soon as you sit down at
the table about 57 agreed that using qr
codes felt like a chore and 55 agreed
that qr codes were hard to read and
browse through and it actually does seem
to make sense for restaurants to bring
back the physical menus now not just
because customers hate it and they'll
sometimes leave these awful reviews for
restaurants because of the qr codes the
qr codes actually are leading to people
ordering less because if you have a menu
left on the table for example sometimes
it'll have the pictures of the food and
the drinks and the desserts and
everything so you may be tempted to
order more just by giving a glance over
at it and saying oh that looks good i
want to order that whereas if you have
to pull out your phone scan the qr code
open up the website scroll down find
what you're looking for that's more of
an active action versus a passive action
of just glancing at something and saying
that looks good i want that now
depending on my mood i will sometimes
lie at the restaurant and i'll say i
don't have a phone or i have a flip
phone and so i need a physical menu that
is something that you can try out at
home there they'll have a few physical
menus at their ready so they're probably
not going to be happy to give it to you
but you can always just make up an
excuse and i'm sure you'll get it and
another pro tip for dealing with the
other inconvenience that people
absolutely hate at restaurants is when
you're about to pay for the meal just
have cash handy with the tip included so
that when the server comes over you can
just pay for it all at once they bring
you the check you look at the amount you
probably know about what it's going to
be you just give them the cash they go
on with it rather than having to give
them a card they leave come back and
then you fill out the tip and everything
it saves you about half the headache
because that's one of the things that
people hate most about restaurants
having to wait at the end of your meal
when you just want to get up and leave
all right that's going to do it for
today's show my thank you to david for
allowing me to fill in for him today
while he is traveling up in montreal and
we're going to have farron cousins fill
in the next couple of days david will be
back on thursday and friday to finish
out the week
and if you want more of the david pakman
show be sure to check out today's bonus
show which you can access by signing up
for a membership at joinpacman.com
or contributing to patreon at the five
dollar level at patreon.com
davidpakinshow i'll see you on the bonus
show